CORRIE ELSTON: Good afternoon.
My name's Corrie Elston.
I'm the CTO of Financial
Services for Google Cloud
Platform.
We're very lucky this afternoon
to have Matt Taylor with us.
Matt's the CTO of Kensho.
Now Matt's going to do a
proper introduction to himself
and Kensho in a few minutes.
But I just wanted to start
off by saying that Kensho's
an extraordinary company that's
pioneering real-time statistics
and analytics, machine learning
for financial services.
Now Matt and I
this afternoon are
going to talk about Kensho on
Google Cloud Platform, machine
learning in your browser.
And we've got a real
treat, because Matt's
come up with a custom
TensorFlow machine learning
model based on
Kensho's data that he's
going to demonstrate for us.
Now, we're going to split this
presentation into two portions.
I'm going to lead off
relatively quickly.
And I'll tell you about
why Google Cloud Platform's
the best place for you to do
your analytics and machine
learning-- not just a good
option or a good place,
but the best place for you
to do those activities.
Matt's then going to
take over, and he's
going to talk about Kensho
and machine learning.
But I just realized
I made a mistake.
When I was preparing for
this, I didn't sort of
take into account
that we'd be doing it
right early in the afternoon.
So how was lunch for everybody?
A good lunch?
Everybody get ready for the
sessions this afternoon,
in San Francisco this evening?
A thumbs-up for lunch?
All right, so I sort of
transparently recovered
from my mistake, and now we can
go onto some machine learning.
Modern machine intelligence,
a branch of computer science
to build systems to
perform similar functions
to human intelligence, such
as learning, reasoning,
self-correcting, and adapting.
And it allows us to do
some astonishing things.
Just within financial services,
which is my specialization,
it allows us to manage
risk much more effectively.
It allows us to survey
activity much more effectively.
In essence, it promises
to be the piece that
was missing for so long
where people thought
that financial markets
were so inherently
complicated that they
couldn't be understood.
But you've seen again,
you've seen the presentations
where machine learning,
TensorFlow, Google Cloud
Platform give us the
opportunity to bring
that understanding to very
high dimensionality data.
And of course the caveat is
that there's more and more data.
The amount of data is
increasing exponentially.
The need to make
use of that data
is becoming ever more pressing.
So we need to scale,
sometimes enormously,
and we also need to
move very quickly
and experiment and break
stuff very regularly.
And that's where Google
Cloud Platform comes in,
to give you scale and
the ability to interact.
Which leads us to a premised
architecture for analysis
and machine learning.
I'm not going to spend
much time at all going
through the boxes
on this slide apart
from saying that each of these
services is fully managed,
no operations.
Each of them offers best
functionality, wonderful price,
and performance.
What I do want just want to
spend a couple of minutes
talking about are
the things that I
built over the last
12 to 18 months
using these building
blocks, because that's
where the rubber
really hits the road.
And that was the context that
I wanted to share with you.
What I've done can
inform what you're
going to build going forward.
And hopefully it will inform
what we'll build together.
Number one, I built a proof
of concept using Dataflow that
took 10,000 30-year time
series of financial data
and correlated
everything by everything,
50 million correlations of
30 years' worth of data,
three minutes, at 300,000
correlations per second,
compared to running on a 16 core
server where I turned it off
after 12 hours
because it was just,
if it doesn't
finish in 12 hours,
that effectively sort of
goes towards infinity to me.
It was very boring
to wait for it.
I built a proof of concept
using Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
Cloud Storage, and Bigtable
that ingested a simulated market
data feed of all
North American market
data in graduations of a quarter
million events per second.
Did that from Pub/Sub, and
I also did it as files.
Took about two days
to code that up,
and it took zero overhead in
setting it up and bringing it
down.
Interestingly, I also
built Spark clusters
to do a grid search of
that data using Dataproc.
Those clusters of 25
servers took less than a
minute to come up,
took about 45 seconds
based on my testing, which
means I was able to do that grid
search by instantiating
and then tearing down
whole clusters of machines.
Finally and recently,
we built a machine
learning model that spans
Spark, ML, and TensorFlow to put
an ensemble together, to
see how those things worked.
And with that, I
wanted to hand it over
to Matt who's going to talk
about what Kensho's doing.
Thank you very much.
MATT TAYLOR: Thank you Corrie.
Our partnership with Google on
GCP has been a real pleasure.
And I think one of the things
that attracted us to Google
was the collaborative
nature in which we
get to develop our products.
He's also done a
fantastic job of kind
of showing off the raw power
that GCP provides to us.
So today I'm going to
give you a personal look
under the hood of Kensho,
what our mission is,
how we think about the world.
And most importantly, we'll
walk through a machine learning
experiment together, letting
the computer identify
what days are like this.
So Kensho is a high-end
analytics platform
for the financial industry.
Think machine learning powered
hedge fund analytics delivered
via the browser.
If you work at a major
bank or a major hedge fund,
you're probably already
aware of our platform.
If you've watched
CNBC, you've likely
seen the Kensho stats box where
their anchors use our platform
to analyze events in the news.
While we deliver hedge
fund caliber analytics,
we're not a hedge fund.
And that's one of
the nice things
that I can do today
is as a startup,
as a technology company,
I can come and give you
a peek under the hood of how
we treat financial analysis.
This is making sophisticated
financial analysis
more accessible,
intuitive, and beautiful.
Now as part of the Kensho
team and a back-end data
nerd at heart, I'm passionate
about deleting code and using
technology to
understand the world.
Machine learning accomplishes
both of these goals.
I joined Kensho
in 2013, and I now
quarterback the engineering,
data science, and design teams.
And every day I rely
heavily on my experience
building low-level
financial infrastructure,
high-frequency trading, and
delivering millions of cat GIFs
at Tumblr.
Kensho and our machine learning
on Google Cloud Platform
is the unity of these goals.
Make it smart, make it
fast, and make it beautiful.
Founded in 2013, Kensho,
like most three-year-olds,
we're curious about the world.
We come with few
preconceived notions.
We're eager to learn.
And we adapt quickly
to new information.
We do this via search,
discovery, analysis, knowledge
graph, event database.
We deal with single assets,
macro events, geopolitical,
weather.
And today we're going
to ask the machine
to identify days like this.
So like any good
experiment, we're
going to start with a
testable hypothesis.
We're going to plan
for our experiment.
We're going to structure
a specific test.
And we're going to let the
machine drive our analysis.
Then we're going to feed it
back into the Kensho platform
and see how the markets react.
So if you've read a "Random
Walk Down Wall Street"
and believe an
efficient market theory,
you probably think
that the answer is no.
If you recall the financial
crisis and the Great Recession,
you might think
asset prices can be
grossly mispriced for
prolonged periods of time.
You might think
the answer is yes.
Using market events
and other features,
can I gain insight into
what may happen tomorrow?
Let's find out what
the computer thinks.
In order to maximize
learning, there's
two things that we really need.
And for hungry, lean companies,
the most important question
is, what is the most valuable
thing I can learn right now?
And the two things I need are
resources and proper timing.
So I want to take a
step back for a second
and talk about those
two things to make sure
now is the time to act.
Now for resources, I borrow a
lot from the same challenging
questions that face
our own education
system, about educating
our best and brightest
to keep America competitive
across a global marketplace.
You need physical safety
to explore and experience
what the world is around you.
You need resources to fuel and
encourage and to grow with you.
You need a community
of mentors, guides,
and helping you
correct mistakes.
You need a culture
that encourages
you to learn from mistakes,
to try lots of things,
and to fail quickly.
But above all, you have
to always be learning.
And if we apply
this same approach
to how we teach our machines,
and then how our machines teach
us-- data center, security,
CPU, disk, the network
capacity, unparalleled
access to APIs, data,
the right permissions to
not do the wrong things,
we can do really powerful stuff.
There becomes a tipping
point in the ecosystem
where it feeds back onto itself
and becomes a multiplier.
Now the second thing we need
in addition to resources
was timing.
And this is critical.
And one of the
things that struck me
was thinking about one
of my favorite things
in all the world, the
Large Hadron Collider.
It took 10 years to build it--
10 years, from 1998 to 2008.
It was a significant
international collaborative
effort by CERN.
It needed years of
theoretical testing
and smaller attempts to
build smaller colliders.
It didn't have its first
test run until 2010.
But it all paid off.
In 2012, they discovered
the Higgs boson,
and is now being
used to measure some
of the highest-energy
collisions in the world.
I want to compare that to
what Kensho gets from GCP.
Instead of investing a
generation of knowledge
and science, and
instead of investing
a half a decade of
infrastructure build-out
and another decade to
actually get it running,
we spent minutes.
We measure our
scientific process
in minutes of time and money.
Founded in 2013, we use
machine learning on GCP
to power our platform.
Now what struck me
at this is Google
was founded in 1998 as well, the
same year they started building
the Large Hadron Collider.
And while we can run countless
experiments every day
and scale up those experiments
to the largest in the world,
I asked myself, why
are we able to do this?
How can we go from a
generational planning
to doing science and
data science and research
and machine learning in minutes?
We're standing on top
of the other thing that
started in 1998.
Google has more than a decade
of building out infrastructure,
security, data expertise.
And it struck me at
yesterday's keynote,
Diane Greene mentioned that
Google spends $9.9 billion
every year on capex.
And it cost approximately
$9.9 billion
to build the Large
Hadron Collider.
So we are standing upon
the Large Hadron Collider
equivalent of cloud computing.
And that means we can start
signing customers, solving
our problems, and
doing machine learning
without having to build 17 miles
of tunnel underneath Europe.
So if we have resources
and we have the timing
is right, because we can
do our experiments measured
in minutes, and we can do
those experiments in parallel
with everyone else who wants
to use this Large Hadron
Collider at the same time.
It's clear the time
to get started.
So let's move right away to
designing our experiment.
So the first thing we're
going to do is we're
going to gather various
measures of sector performance--
their momentum, liquidity,
volatility, pricing, trends,
historical ranges of prices.
We're going to want to
normalize that data,
perhaps into log space.
We're going to adjust
the ranges of the data
to prevent outliers from
squishing our data into buckets
that prevent them from being
distinguished from each other.
Then we're going to use
unsupervised machine learning
to identify key features
that have existed in market
days previous to this.
Then we're going to use
unsupervised machine learning
to cluster those and
identify what days
are most similar to each other.
And then we're going
to take this model,
feed it back into Kensho,
and we're going to ask,
what will happen the next day?
So let's recall our hypothesis.
So now we're going
to take a moment
to ask you to log out of
your retirement accounts.
While machine learning
is amazingly powerful
and amazingly cool,
I'm an engineer, not
a financial advisor.
Don't day trade your
retirement account.
So the first thing I
said we're going to do
is we're going to gather
and normalize our data.
We do this in a compositional,
API-driven fashion
that is powered by
Google Cloud Platform.
In this case, we
take a configuration
and we inject it with time
series information, event
from our knowledge base and
our event almanac, measures
of price and momentum
and liquidity.
And behind the scenes, we're
going to normalize and clean up
that data.
I said this would just
be the good parts.
This compositional style
of machine learning
means we can leverage
all that Google
has to offer in one notebook.
In this case, I'm pulling
in almost 4,300 days
of market data with about
64 features for every day.
So we love matrices.
And so do computers and so
does machine learning models.
In this case, we're using
single value decomposition
to remove redundant data.
I'm not helping the
computer very much here.
This is the computer
telling me, hey,
I found some stuff you really
didn't need to include.
It's not that valuable.
And in this case,
SVD says I can remove
a chunk of your information
and still keep almost 98%
of the distinguishing
characteristics.
I'm asking the
computer literally
to say what can I throw away.
The next thing that
we're going to do
is throw this into a
model called t-SNE.
In longer form, it's
t-distributed stochastic
neighbor embedding.
This reduces the
dimensionality of the data
from 64 dimensions down to two.
But it does not preserve
the state of the data.
It is helpful for plotting it
in a human-understandable space.
But I do want to emphasize, in
just a couple lines of code,
I have told the
computer almost nothing.
I'm challenging the
computer to tell me.
I'm going to continue
to be very lazy.
I'm not going to pick or
estimate the number of clusters
that we should use beforehand.
I'm not going to
make assumptions
about the internal
data structure.
Affinity propagation essentially
says, what information
is passed from previous states
in the data to future states?
And the computer will
figure this out on its own.
As we layer these clusters
in two-dimensional space,
the silhouette score
will give us essentially
what it sounds like it is--
an overlay of the data.
And to what extent
do the shadows
or silhouettes of those clusters
overlap or fit with each other?
Now a terrible fit would
say, I'm in a cluster,
but I really belong
in some other cluster.
And a great fit
would say, I'm so
happy in my current
cluster I would never
want to be anywhere else.
It's not even close.
And the scores for a silhouette
range from negative 1 to 1.
In this case we have a 0.15.
We're doing OK.
I've seen better.
We can continue to improve it.
So let's visualize
this in two dimensions.
So this is a pretty graph.
There's some larger areas where
a lot of days appear similar.
There's some tighter
clusters that seem
to be really close together.
Now Kensho deals so much
with historical precedents
that for me, I'm drawn
to the clusters that
have a lot of days.
This allows me to go back
and measure things that have
hundreds of days in similarity.
But taking a moment, I've
already learned something here.
I can go pluck out clusters
that only have two in them
or three days in them.
And just the fact
that these days
seem to be so distinguished
from all the others
can make them notable as well.
If as the market day rolls on I
find the most similar days are
one of these tiny
clusters that seems to not
be similar to
anything else, that
can potentially be valuable
information all by itself.
So as the computer starts
organizing and sorting
your data and giving
you perspective
on what is common
versus uncommon,
it gives you the power as a
human to make a judgment about,
is this rare?
And if it's rare, what do I do?
Or maybe it just sounded
rare, and now the computer
is telling me no, this
happens all the time.
We ran into this with the
drop of the price of oil.
We went from about
$140, dropped to $100.
And there was a big
discussion around that,
because a $40 drop
in oil is enormous.
But is it?
And we were able to
Kensho to show that it
wasn't an unusual event.
It wasn't a buying opportunity.
There was room for it to drop,
because on a percentage basis,
oil dropping 20% or
30% was not uncommon.
And as the summer went on,
oil dropped to $70, to $60.
And more recently it
was down in the $30s.
So just the quantity
and how rare
something is is
valuable by itself.
So let's look at a specific day.
And in this case, I
have chosen February 23,
so about a month ago.
This particular cluster has
a couple hundred precedents
in it.
And in this case I'm
looking at other dates.
And I've bucketed them by month.
In machine learning,
as the feeble human
who's participating
in this task,
I find histograms
immensely useful
because it gives me a sense
of the shape of the data,
how it's laid out,
how the computer
has organized it for me.
And then I can look at this
and say, that's interesting.
So what's interesting about it?
Well, for one, I see there's a
lot more days like February 23
more recently.
There's a jump in 2014, 2015.
I don't see much in 2010, 2011,
2012, little spike in 2008,
not much in 2007.
And then I go back
into the early '00s.
I see there's more
clusters of data.
And intuitively, I
find this makes sense.
The regime of the market
from the financial crisis
to about 2014 or early '15
was a long steady march
up to the right.
It was recovering from
the Great Recession.
People's confidence
was going up.
The stock market was--
earnings were strong.
Revenue growth was strong.
The housing market
was showing signs
of recovery and stabilization.
There was a quantitative
easing program
going on that helped
fuel this progress.
And then as we approached
the 2015 window,
people started to think,
maybe the federal government
is going to start unwinding
quantitative easing.
People's confidence
started to rebound.
People started to talk
a lot more about jobs.
So it says to me that perhaps
this machine has learned
something about the
structure of the market
and the overall
tone of the sectors
and how they behaved
with each other
as it changed from leading
into the financial crisis
to the financial
crisis to recovery
from the financial
crisis to now.
So what I want to do is I
want to take a moment now
to feed this into Kensho,
and we're going to ask,
what happens on days
like February 23?
Can we switch to the demo?
So we're not a hedge fund.
We put out a website.
We sell our product to major
financial institutions.
And what I've done here
is extracted the dates
that the machine has
told me are similar.
I have fed them into
our analysis engine.
In this case I have
256 previous dates.
Again, you can see
the histogram of how
they are clustered by days.
So I'm going to ask the system
a very specific question.
If I buy on the close
of days like February 23
and I sell it the
next day, how do I do?
So I'm literally
taking, on February 23,
I see we're coming
into the close.
The markets are open
from 9:30 to 4:00.
Coming to a close, say
it's 3:30 in the day,
and I look at the stock prices.
I look at my portfolio.
I look at what's going
on in macro levels.
I look at how the
sectors are performing.
I look at what's in the news.
I run and I ask the machine,
what days are like today?
And the machine has told me, I
found more than 250 precedents.
It's going to say, if I were
to buy-- if this ends up
being just like how I think
it's going to shape up
over the last half hour of
trading, what should I buy?
Or if I'm already
holding it, maybe I
should sell, reduce my
risk, reduce my exposure.
In this case, I'm just going to
do some liquid ETFs, materials,
energy, consumer discretionary,
financials, technology stocks.
The results, we can analyze what
happens on all of those dates.
We compute, on the fly, more
than 85 different statistics
from beta-adjusted
returns to p-values
to your actual raw or
average daily returns.
We adjust for dividends,
corporate actions.
You can see the dispersion
in how the various market
sectors pan out.
There's not tight clustering
around those events.
In this case, I'm looking
at the beta-adjusted return.
This helps normalize
the performance
of the various sectors
relative to the benchmark.
So I'm looking
for outperformance
or underperformance rather than
just maybe everything went up
on that given day.
So what happens?
So in this case, I'm going
to treat this returns
chart as a stack rank.
And it seems like
in this case energy
has historically outperformed.
Materials is up there.
We have down at the bottom,
XLF is the financials.
I see health care
seems to underperform.
So in this kind of
thing, I might say hey,
let me look at my holdings.
Am I overweight health care?
Should I do
something about that?
If I was planning
on buying energy,
should I buy it today
rather than tomorrow?
And lastly, we
give our customers
all the raw data output.
We run tests, t-tests, both
one-sided and two-sided,
depending on the scenario
that you're trying to measure,
about looking for fat tail
risk and looking for shifts
in the distribution of returns.
We also look a lot
about time series.
So the way machine learning
teaches us about time series,
we then feed that into
a visualization that
allows us to appreciate what
the machine has identified
and overlay that with how
the market has performed.
So I'm going to say, sell
health care and buy some energy
or hedge my positions
on the 24th.
So this allows me to
do something different.
So now I'm actually
asking, what happened?
I bought some
stocks on the close.
And now I held them.
And here I am on the 24th
holding these stocks.
So what happened
to my portfolio?
So I see materials
has done quite well.
I see energy is
still up at the top.
I see health care has
nudged a little bit.
I'm not sure if
there's something here,
but it does seem like the
top has generally stabilized.
The bottom has
generally stabilized.
And there's some shuffling or
mixing around in the middle.
And it's this kind of thing.
I've told the computer
almost nothing other
than here's some market data.
Remove what I don't need.
Group it together.
Reduce the dimensionality.
Identify signals that are
passed from previous states
to future state.
And then fed that back into
an analysis engine to say,
well, this looks like
this kind of day.
What happens tomorrow?
And when I look at this, I
say this is not a random walk.
Can we go back to
my slides, please?
So let's bring
this all together.
We're really doing is
talking about understanding
the connections of things.
How are things
connected to each other?
We're statistically annotating
the significance of what
has happened in the market.
So we're looking at
two market assets.
There's a major publicity event.
A company has earnings.
There's unrest in
the Middle East.
There's a new product announced
by a specific company.
To what extent does
that influence or alter
how that asset performs in the
future, through market assets?
That means events happening in
the world, news happening now,
and to what extent does
that change our perception
of the likelihood or the
significance of events
coming in the future?
And then lastly, market
assets by themselves
can influence what
will happen as well.
And I'll go back again to
the drop in the price of oil,
where you can see how the
drop in the price of oil
has caused ramifications
in the Middle East
around the structure
of those governments
and their ability
to pay their bills.
It's affected
Alaska, which is now
having to start
considering income taxes
and change their budget
economics quite dramatically.
And ultimately through
machine learning,
we're answering the question,
who should care, and how much?
And if you decide that you
do or don't care, when?
When should you care?
When is it important?
When is the time to
act, and for how long?
Now, I got a very interesting
question this morning
as I was watching the keynote.
And the person next to me
asked me about machine learning
and said, is this a
biological process
or is this a
mathematical process?
I think that's a
fantastic question.
Because at the top
level, machine learning,
neural networks
especially, they behave
like a biological process.
There's layers to them.
There's nuance.
They incorporate new things.
As new data comes in, you can
incrementally train your model
in the same way that a child
discovering a toy or gravity
or getting to visit the
Large Hadron Collider
incorporates new
information into its already
existing perception and
knowledge of the world.
But if you zoom into the
micro details of the model,
you're trying to back out, does
this machine really get it?
Do they really find
stuff that I can't see?
And you look at the individual
layers of the model,
it starts to look like math.
It is math.
It's matrices.
It's numbers.
And you can peel apart
the layers of, say,
a neural network and see at
each layer, what does it know,
and how does this change what
it knew from the previous layer,
in the same way we might
test a child in school
to say, what did
you learn this year,
and compare that to how
they did the previous year.
And this is our brains as well.
We think of our brains
as a biological process,
because they are.
It's lots of connections.
It's flaws.
We learn something.
We unlearn it later.
But then you zoom
into the micro detail,
and our brains are
firing neurons.
It's ones and zeros.
Did it fire or not?
And so when I look
at how we analyze
the connectedness of things
in the world, the increasing
velocity at which
information comes in,
we rely increasingly
heavily on the computers
to process this information,
like the prodigy
that it is, at a velocity
that I can't match.
And it tells me things.
And that allows me to
delete code, replace it
with models that
learn and update,
and then go back to solving
my customer's problem.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
I can do some questions.
I have about 10
minutes if people
would like to ask questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If we're
deciding if today
is similar to other days in the
past, what data did you use?
MATT TAYLOR: So the
question is, what
data did I use to decide
what was similar in the past?
In this particular model, I
was using pricing, volume,
volatility, ranges, moving
averages, various ETFs
representing various sectors.
There's a lot more stuff
that you can pull in
and layer increasing nuance
on top of these things.
For example, one
thing we frequently do
is we'll pull in when earnings
and other major shock level
events will affect an asset.
The volume of ETFs has
increased and varied over years,
so you probably
want an ARIMA model
that normalizes some
of the seasonality out
of those things.
I probably could have
picked additional sectors,
or even want to study
something at a macro level.
Rather in this case I
was looking at something
that was very US centric.
So one of the things we find
very valuable about being
able to run rapid
experiments in the cloud
is you want to
pull in more data,
we can scale up the
computers to do that.
If the experiment seems
not to be fruitful,
we throw that away.
We didn't have to build
out a huge infrastructure
and then scurry around trying to
get teams to make sure they're
always utilizing it.
The second part is it allows
us to study sample sets.
And if it looks promising,
then we scale up the project
accordingly.
So I think the big [INAUDIBLE]
is, the compositional style
allows us to inject different
features and different data
and play with that.
And then when we find something,
we can iterate on that.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Have you
tried feeding this model
with historical
data, but omitting
some of the significant days,
and see if your model could
have predicted those?
CORRIE ELSTON: Yes.
So the question is,
can you essentially do
an in-sample, out-sample test.
So you take, say, 80%
or 85% of your days.
You train on that data.
And then you use it as an out
of sample test on the other 15%
or 20% of the data.
In this case, I think you'd want
to pull in additional features
in order to do that
well, so please
don't trade the strategy.
But at the same time, that's
exactly the right thing to do.
And the other nice thing,
because we have this complement
of machine learning and
back-testing analysis,
we're able to
check those things.
And then the incremental
layering of machine learning
allows you to constantly
incorporate new information.
It would be like, what
did I miss yesterday?
Let me incorporate that.
What did I get right?
Let me reinforce that.
And so the model of learning
is very much fail quickly,
do again.
But machines, unlike maybe
humans, don't develop a bias.
Our feelings don't get hurt
if you're constantly wrong.
Computers don't get discouraged.
And so then their velocity
of running experiments
so fast is such a
multiplier that they're
able to fail so many times until
they get it right, at a scale
that none of us can match.
Michael?
AUDIENCE: So did it
predict February 24?
CORRIE ELSTON: I think
it got some things right
and some things wrong, in that
I think the general-- if you
think of it as like
layers of sediment,
the things that were generally
doing well historically
were generally toward
the top, and things
that were doing poorly were
generally toward the bottom.
But I think you'd
again want to-- I
wouldn't go trade your
retirement account based
on that.
And I think there's more
you could layer in there.
But yeah, I think
in general it seemed
to have some sorting there.
And a sophisticated
financial investor
would probably look at some
sort of weighted strategy
that would buy some
things at a higher
ratio or short other things or
sell things in a various ratio
to potentially hedge or
leverage opportunity.
AUDIENCE: Did it
identify any days
that had never happened before?
CORRIE ELSTON: So the
question is, did it
identify any days that
had never happened before?
So there was a bunch.
So we have a precedent
engine, right?
So we use machine
learning to identify
precedents of when something
has happened like this.
And if there aren't
many precedents,
then you really can't run a test
on what has happened before,
although it may be valuable
to know it hasn't happened.
So when there are
small clusters,
I just basically threw
out ones that had,
I think, it was just a
handful of days in them,
because I don't have a
robust statistical way
of feeding those back in
to do analysis on those.
But certainly, say, if
I had a dashboard that
tells me going into
the close, hey,
this looks kind of unprecedented
because of these reasons
and why, that's something that,
at the scale of the information
coming into the system,
no individual could do.
Microphone, yes?
AUDIENCE: So the
Python code you showed
is written inside
a browser, and that
would trigger your
machine learning library
on Google Cloud Platform?
CORRIE ELSTON: Yes,
so the question
being-- the question's
about coding in the browser,
using an IPython notebook.
So we love APIs.
We love services.
We love compositional services.
So one of the things we do
is we build our own services,
our own models.
We use Google's services
and Google's APIs.
And then that allows
our data scientists
to work in an IPython notebook.
And that essentially serves
as a journal of what this is.
And they can pull things in.
And if the experiment
doesn't work out,
we can stash that in
a Git repo and someone
can pick it up later or
at least learn from that.
And so the way we do
this , we have an API--
I didn't show it here-- that
we can kick off analysis
in the background and
pull those back in.
AUDIENCE: So instead of Google's
TensorFlow-based machine
learning framework, you
manage your own machine
learning models and libraries?
CORRIE ELSTON: We do both.
I got just a couple
more minutes.
Right here?
AUDIENCE: Have you
applied your model
to other data sets-- I'm just
curious-- as an experiment
other than financials?
CORRIE ELSTON: Yes.
We've certainly
played around with it.
We're very much focused
on financial information
right now.
The financial industry is
heavily focused on security.
They have very high
standards for robustness,
throughput, the large scale
data which keeps it interesting.
There's clients, there's an
immediate hunger, like answer
now.
And I think that
has a lot of analogs
across many different
sectors and data sets.
We ingest a large
variety of data.
So it's not just numbers
from market data,
but we also do
world events, news.
We have unstructured
data that we
parse out and do
entity identification
and to kind of tease
out what's connected.
We feed a lot of that
into our knowledge graph
so that we can understand
the connectedness of things,
like proverbial, you could
shake the knowledge graph
and see what else
shakes, and for how much,
and over what amount of time.
And our knowledge graph has
object-oriented structure to it
that allows us to
validate things.
And a lot of those
annotations are time-related,
because we love mapping
things to time series,
allows us to throw into matrices
and do machine learning on it.
Microphone.
AUDIENCE: When you're talking
about doing machine learning,
you're working with
historical data.
But in the past, there
were no other companies
doing machine learning on data
in the early 2000s, 1990s.
So how do you say that
your model is valid
compared to historical data when
all financial institutions are
doing this kind of analysis now?
CORRIE ELSTON: Sure,
so the question
being that lots of
people are doing this.
And I think it's true.
For example, Google's been doing
this for quite a long time.
And I think a big chunk
of machine learning
is knowing what to
pay attention to
and letting the
computer advise that.
And I think a lot of what's
going to revolutionize
the finance industry and
many other industries as well
is they're going to
move to the cloud.
They're going to use machine
learning to remove code.
learning to analyze data.
They're going to do it
in near to real time.
And then the humans
will be enlightened
as a result of that.
So it flips the
teacher-student relationship.
As an engineer, I'm so used
to basically spelling out
a recipe for the computer.
Do A, then B, then C, or call
A and then call B on that
or call C on that.
And this flips the relationship.
So now it's rather
than a couple people
trying to teach a
lot of machines,
we basically say
here's the framework
and data for the
machines to learn,
and then they will teach us.
And that I think is an immensely
powerful paradigm switch
that flips everything.
There was another
question back there?
I got-- last one.
AUDIENCE: I have been
playing with Watson.
And the ability to
actually type in a question
and then it understands
the semantics of what
you are asking or the context
of what you're asking,
it gives you an answer.
Have you built any of
that into your product?
And have you leveraged any
of Google's machine learning
algorithms to do that?
CORRIE ELSTON: Yes, so we love
natural language processing.
I think it's a
very intuitive way.
Search is a very
powerful tool for us
and for the financial industry.
We have a query engine
where you can type
in more free-form questions.
Where I think it becomes
exponentially powerful
is I shouldn't have
to ask the computer.
So we're evolving
from a world that
says, computer what about
this, what about this,
what about this, and it
behaves like hunt and peck.
And we're coming to a world
where we say no, like computer,
just let me know when it's
important, when I should care,
for how much and how long.
And so I think they both
play off to each other.
The other area where
we use a lot of NLP
is on the ingestion
side to identify things.
And you can use
hidden Markov models
to pull out structure
and implications
without even necessarily
needing entity identification.
So there's a lot of cool
stuff coming out there.
And Google's a major
leader in that area,
especially on the tech side.
All right, last one.
AUDIENCE: Can you extend
the point on the analysis
for do you sell [INAUDIBLE]?
Let's say natural
language processing
before you could
put it in anything.
CORRIE ELSTON: Yeah,
so the question
is, do we sell the final
product or do we perhaps sell
pieces of it?
The answer is we do both.
So we're building
a platform that
is very flexible, has
many layers to it we
can scale separately.
We follow the Google GCP
model of microservices
and being able to
expose those to have
the right layer of abstraction.
And we potentially open those
up as they become ready.
Cool.
Thank you so much, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]